[Musique]
salut Christine salut Katie
joyeux anniversaire moi et Toby avions un
petit goûter seuls les bébés ont
des amis imaginaires
Toby sortent tu ne devrais pas faire ça bien
je suis ce que certains bizarres se passent mais si
j'installe quelques caméras autour du  maison
allons-y les gars
n'est-ce pas le même symbole de la
chambre des filles Julie Julie
Katie éloignez-vous de ça quoi qu'il
nous soit arrivé quand nous étions petits je ne me
souviens de rien monsieur a fait du bien ouais
chasseur est le premier mâle à être né sur
Christy  côté depuis les années 1930
pensez-vous que c'est bon vous savez que c'est vraiment
facile d'avoir cette famille pourrait la quitter je
pense que ça recommence humain fait un
marché avec un démon doit renoncer à
leur premier-né mâle
oh mon dieu pense que c'est du sang Jang
Hajin regarde donner  lui lac regarde le
point donc plus de choses bizarres se passent
ou pas tout va bien
comment il perd la tête j'ai juste euh j'ai l'
impression qu'il se passe des trucs dans notre
maison au point où je
m'en ai parlé et je suis sûr  il pense que je suis
fou
[Musique]
Daniel c'est simple bouge elle c'est la maison
du nouveau voisin sa maman à l'
hôpital il n'a pas de parents je ne sais pas
je n'ai jamais rencontré sa maman je pense qu'il
y a quelque chose dans ma maison
3:  00 du matin peux-tu me dire à qui
tu parles
[Musique]